you talk about some of those rescues by
both there have also been rescues by air
and mark Strassmann is in Elizabeth City
this morning at a Coast Guard Station
which is prepped and ready mark morning
GF uh this is a Coast Guard Jayhawk
search-and-rescue helicopter there are a
number of people out there who need
rescuing and a number of people who
likely will need rescuing in the days
ahead with all the rains to come some
have waited for help on their own roofs
and that's why this helicopter needs to
get in the air it can hover over people
in crisis pull them up in a basket or
harness from rooftops and other
hard-to-reach places these helicopters
and rescue crews are ready to go problem
is the weather has mostly been too rough
to fly too dangerous to fly but take a
look at this Coast Guard video one
rescue team managed to pick up a cancer
patient last night in critical condition
along with a paramedic it took them from
a fire station to Morehead City to the
hospital captain Joe deer who commands
the Coast Guard Air Station here says as
soon as the weather calms down all his
rescue choppers will go up to send the
helicopters what are the kinds of crises
like what kind of situations do people
have to be in feeders in the helicopter
well life-threatening emergencies
vessels sinking people in the water
people on rooftops getting caught you
know in Russian water and hitting will
respond to things like that
wherever the the loss of life is
possible that's will push the envelope
to try and respond to that
here's the good news the weather
actually has improved this morning and
one of these Jayhawks is now enroute to
Jacksonville North Carolina that's
around the Camp Lejeune area there are
reports of 13 stranded people who need
rescuing including children and elderly
Jeff mark thanks very much